ينضم الينا من لاهاي جيرمي كوربن النائب
المستقل في البرلمان البريطاني والزعيم
السابق لحزب العمال مرحبا بك السيد جيرمي
كوربن لماذا بدايه تتواجد في لاهاي
بالتزامن مع انطلاق جلسات محكمه محكمه
العدل الدوليه في الدعوه التي قدمتها جنوب
افريقيا طيب اذا من جديد نذكر بان معنا من
لاهاي جيرمي كوربن النائب المستقل في
البرلمان البريطاني والزعيم السابق لحزب
العمال نرحب بك من جديد سيد جيرمي كوربن
ونسالك بدايه لماذا تتواجد في لاهاي في
هذه الاثناء بالتزامن مع انطلاق جلسات
الدعوه التي رفعتها جنوب افريقيا على
اسرائيل في محكمه العدل
الدوليه
هناك اهميه عالميه لهذه القضيه فالتي
رفعتها جنوب افريقيا الى محكمه العدل
الدوليه لمحاوله عرض قضيه ضد اسرائيل
لانها انتهكت معاهده الاباده الجماعيه
وصباح اليوم قدموا حاله قضيه تفصيليه تثير
الاعجاب وبالتالي لايقاف والدعوه الى وقفه
قصف
غزه سيد جرمي باعتقادك ومن متابعتك
للمرافعات التي جرت اليوم ما الذي يجدر
بمحكمه العدل الدوليه او كيف يجدر بمحكمه
العدل الدوليه ان تتعامل مع هذه
القضيه ان قد طلب من المحكمه ان
تقدم امرا موقتا ضد اسرائيل لاقا بايقاف
قصف غزه وايقاف كل العمليات العسكريه اما
من قبل قوات الدفاع الاسرائيليه او
العملاء ال يعملنا
لحسابها وسمعنا ذلك نهايه جلسات اليوم ومن
قبل الفريق جنوب افريقيا وكانت طالبا قويا
غدا ستقدم اسرائيل جوابها وبعد ذلك قد
نامل ان يصدر هذا القرار بشكل سريع لكن
القضيه قدمت بشكل جيد جدا اظهرت بالتفاصيل
رعب وبشاعه قتل حوالي 3 ال شخص من ذلك
اداد كبيره الاطفال وجرائم الحرب بقصف
المدارس والمستشفيات وتدمير 70% من نازل
بيوت سكان غزه لماذا اعتبرت سيد جرمي ان
هذه القضيه وهذه المحكمه ستشكل منعطفا
تاريخيا لماذا من وجهه
نظرك اعتقد انها فعلا منعطفا تاريخ
لان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الضفه الغربيه
وغزه امر معروف جدا وقد حصل سابقا كان
هناك جهود سابقه قانونيه في قبل اسرائيل
لانتهاكها اتفاقيات جنيف لكن هذه القضيه
مهمه جدا لان يمكن ان نضف اليها قضيه
الاباده جماعيه والتي لابد ان تكون هجوما
على الشعب فلسطين بشكل عام شعب غزه بشكل
عام
و وكعمل سياسي تقوم به الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وقوات الدفاع الاسرائيليه اذا
لقد اوضح في المحكمه بشكل لابس فيها بان
الراي هو الراي هو ضد الدفا القوات
الاسرائيليه ولم يك لديك هناك لديك مشكله
كشعب اسرائيل لان ما فقط الراي هو ضد
الحكومه والجيش الاسرائيلي وليس
الشعب بالقول لانهم يقومون فعلا بعمليه
اباده جماعيه ضد سكان غزه وانا هنا لاحظ
هذا الامر
وتطوراته وانه كان مثيرا للاعجاب ولكنه
يثير الاسف الكثير كيف ان العالم يشاهد
لقطات حيه على التلفزيون كيف يقتل الاطفال
في الشوارع والناس يرجعون حتى الموت
والناس يموتون نتيجه عمليات لان لا يس
تحمل الام اجراء عمليات جراحيه مثل فتر
الاطراف دون مخدر هذه كلها جرائم ضد
الانسانيه وان خساره حياه الصحفيين زيد من
الصحفين قتلوا في غزه من اكثر من اي منطقه
في العالم خلال السنه الماضيه هذا هو ما
يجري امام اعيننا واكثر من 100 وربما اكثر
من من موظفين الامم المتحده ظفين غاث ايضا
تعرضوا للقتل كل هذه الامور هذه ليست
اخطاء تحصل بالصدفه بل هذه اعمال مقصوده
مقصو عنب قصد س هناك توجه من التصريحات
الاوليه الان لدى المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
باتهام هذه المحكمه بانها معاديه للساميه
وبالقول ان هذه التصريحات التي استخدمها
الفريق القانوني لجنوب افريقيا كادل اخرجت
من سياقها وان اسرائيل ترد على هجوم عليها
حصل في السابع من اكتوبر ما رايك
بذلك لم يكن هناك اي معادات للساميه في اي
من التصريحات ظه قدمتها جنوب افريقيا
اليوم وغيرها في
المحكمه من الممكن تماما ان يكون الامر
منتقدا لدوله اسرائيل ومع ما تقوم به وفك
وما يقوم به الجيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي
وتصرفاته دون ان يكون الامر معاد لساميه
الامر هنا يتعلق بحقوق الانسانيه يتعلق
بقانون حقوق الانسان يتعلق بحقوق الشعوب
ان تعيش حياتها وان الهاما الاتهامات
بالعباده الجماعيه قدمت الان رسميا في
المحكمه ضد حكومه وقوات الجيش الاسرائيلي
هذه تهمه خطيره جدا وان لا بد لاسرائيل ان
تجيبه تجيب على الاتهامات بدلا تطلق
اتهامات ان اناس ما كانوا ابدا يقدموا اي
تصريحات معاد ساميه المعاداه الساميه شر
عنصر كاي شر اخر طيب سيد جرمي هناك ايضا
من يقول ما قيمه ان يصدر قرار ربما عن هذه
المحكمه ولا تقوم اسرائيل
بتنفيذه في الواقع علينا ان ننتظر بصدور
القرار من قبل
المحكمه تظار انه ان تقوم المحكمه بالامر
ب وقف اطلاق قصف غزه وامل انه ل المحكمه
توصلت الى هذا القرار ان اسرائيل ستضطر ان
تحترم القرار فورا فهم موقعو على معاهده
الاباده الجماعيه وهم كانوا اول من وقع
على هذه المعاهده في في
الاربعينيات وامل انهم سيحترم ات الزامهم
هذا لكن ناخذ كل مرحله بمرحل لها سمعنا
القضيه اليوم سنسمع الرد غدا والمحكمه
ستقرر لكن في اثناء ذلك بقيه العالم لابد
ان يطالب بوقف اطلاق نار فولي انا افعل
ذلك حاليا في بريطانيا والكثير من الناس
في بريطانيا ولا يفعلون ذلك والدعوه الى
وقف اطلاق وقف المساعدات العسكريه تبعثها
تبعث الى اسرائيل من قبل الولايات المتحده
وغيرها من الدول ايضا انت تقوم وتدعو بوقف
لاطلاق النار ولكن اسرائيل تستمر مستنده
على دعم من حكومات دول كبرى منها الحكومه
البريطانيه هنا ما دوركم في تغيير موقف
الحكومه البريطانيه وما هي دعوتكم للحكومه
البريطانيه بالنظر الى انطلاق هذه المحكمه
وكل ما قيل
فيها
اقول لحكومه بريطانيا كما اقول لحكومه
الولايات المتحده لو كنتم تقدمون الاسلحه
التي تستخدم لقصف المدنيين الابرياء في
غزه فانتم ايضا متواطئون انتم متواطئون
وانتم مشاركون في حقيقه تدمير حياه
المدنيين في غزه ان اللغه في بريطانيا
بدات تغير بشكل كبير بسبب حجم تظاهرات
الخارجه والاجراءات الشعبيه التي خرجت
لدعم الشعب الفلسطيني حضرت اجتماعات
وتظاهرات كثيره مرتين او ثلاث مرات في
الاسبوع منذ شهر اكتوبر في هذا الموضوع
وهي تزداد حجما يوما بعد اخر ولدينا
تظاهره كبيره في لندن يوم السبت نابل ربما
نصف مليون شخص سيشاركون فيها للتعبير عن
ارائهم حكومه البريطانيه لابد ان تستمع
لهم مناسبه هناك انتخابات قادمه في
بريطانيا هذه السنه والشعب لن ينسى هذا
اشكرك جيرمي كوربن النائب المستقل في
البرلمان البريطاني والزعيم السابق لحزب
العمال حدثنا
ل
تفضل فقط ان اقول شكرا جزيلا وانني اعبر
عن اسف الشديد لخساره حياه الصحفيين
الجزائ الجزيره تعدون عملا راع فيظ في
صحفه جده وقد دفعت ثمنا غاليا ذلك فشكرا
لكم شكرا جزيلا لك